we're all familiar with swimming pool
rules no running no splashing and
definitely no drones when the drone went
into the water I thought that goner
[Music]
and they started swimming it's the
coolest thing ever hold your breath
it's the Loon copter the Loon copter is
amazing a vehicle that can travel
through the air on the surface of the
water and then travel underwater come on
we travel to the University of Auckland
to meet project leader dr. Osama row
washed up and asked why he's building
drones that can fly to the pool and take
a dip we did this mostly for fun because
he wanted to but people been contacting
us with all kinds of different ideas
from search and rescue inspection of
pipelines oil spills getting a
bird's-eye view and I'm diving deep and
to do that a drone would make a lot of
sense but it can fly it uses GPS to
pinpoint the location then can dive at
that spot it sounds like the
possibilities are endless the body or
the hull of this vehicle is actually a
acrylic sugar jar of extra cheap nut
glass so we can actually drill through
it rip tea still the Loon copter caught
the attention of the judges at the
annual drones were good competition in
Dubai and we ended up winning this
competition first place in the
international category which came with a
nice trophy and a cool million dollar
check so how these guys made a drone
that can fly and swim when the Loon
copter hits the surface of the water
it's buoyant it's not going to sink so
it has a tank and a pump it fills itself
up and then it begins to sink small
opening here so water goes in and out
out of this section here it fills one
side of this tank quicker than it does
the other that means the Loon copter
falls under the water onto its side
which means the routers now become its
propellers so what's the difference
between high flying and deep diving when
the drone is in the air it needs to spin
the propellers incredibly fast ten
thousand times a minute to push air down
that provides lift to keep it up water
is far more dense that propellers only
have to spin a hundred and eighty times
a minute
to move enough water to propel it
forward once the loom copter wants to
resurface it pumps water out it floats
to the surface itself rides itself then
it can spin the propellers and then it
takes off into the air like a normal
drill amazing